for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out Mufi
university comm thank you and enjoy next
up is electron affinity so we'll start
off with the definition electron
affinity is the energy change often in
kilojoules associated associated with
the addition of one mole of electrons to
one mole of gaseous atoms or ions okay
so here we have a neutral atom to start
off with neutral atom right neutral
gaseous atom right in the gas form and
it's kind of the opposite of ionization
energy we're adding an electron here to
get an anion right anion here okay and
so there's an energy change associated
with that and that energy change is the
electron affinity okay in this case it's
the first electron affinity because
we're adding one electron okay now the
electron affinity can actually be
negative or positive which is why I put
here in the definition is that it's the
energy associated it's the energy
associated with the addition of my Alamo
electrons right because it's not
necessarily required positive would mean
required but negative would indicate
that energy was released okay so here
this is unlike ionization energy which
is always positive okay because with
ionization energy energy is always
required to remove an electron okay now
with electron affinity mmm in most cases
the first electron affinity is negative
okay
why that means energy is released when
an electron is added to an atom why
would that be well electrons are
attracted to the atoms positively
charged nucleus so it's somewhat
favorable when an electron comes in -
towards a positive positive charge okay
now that's for most cases now there are
obviously important exceptions one
really really important exception is the
entire the entire eighth group right the
eighth a group the noble gases right
because they don't want to get an
electron they don't want to lose an
electron they're stable right they're
stable with their completely filled
orbitals further furthermore the
electron affinity number two is positive
and that's always the case which means
that it's it always requires energy to
add a second electron now why would that
be well because the the product of the
electron affinity reaction is an anion
right so you're going to be adding an
electron a negatively charged species to
a negative ion and those things will
repel right which is that here the
electron affinity - we have we start
with that negatively charged ion we'd
add an electron we'd have an eye on that
as a negative two charge okay so that
would require energy and in that you
know in a way similar to ionization
energies each successive or successive
electron affinities are always more
positive okay because if you want to
keep adding electrons to these more and
more negatively charged species more
energy will be required
so let's get into the trend what's going
on with the trend well with electron
affinity across the periodic table or on
the periodic table it increases up and
to the right in the same way that
ionization energy does okay so I'll show
that here increases up and to the right
now of course we have to make sure that
we're excluding the noble gases right we
got to exclude this group excluding
noble gases all right because they're
not trying to gain electrons at all okay
but before we go on when we think about
lowest and highest what I mean we should
frame our thinking of electron affinity
a certain way and and we have to answer
the question what is a high electron
affinity what is a high electron
affinity what is a low electron affinity
what does that even mean right the
reason why I ask is because electron
affinity can be negative or positive
right the energy change associated with
it can be negative or positive so which
direction more negative or more positive
indicates a higher affinity it's a
really important question right because
with ionization energy all the values
were positive so the more positive it
was the higher it was that was pretty
intuitive right but with electron
affinity it's not as intuitive because
you can have negative or positive values
as far as the energy associated with the
reaction so you have to establish a sort
of convention right or at least not
establish an intervention but at least
understand what these values mean well
if you think about the word affinity
affinity pretty much means attraction
okay so if something has a high electron
affinity or a higher affinity for
something then it's more attracted
that's why am i scribbling it's more
attractive so if an element has a high
electron affinity it's attracted to
electrons it wants to gain that electron
okay
gaining an electron would
be favorable okay and as far as
favorable energy changes go a favorable
energy change is a negative energy
change losing energy it's not favorable
for something to require energy right I
mean you can just think about that I'm
lazy I don't want to do things that
requires energy
that's not favorable I wanted to be lazy
and get by with as little as possible
right you losing energy or releasing
energy is favorable okay so think about
this number line that I've have here as
we go to the right we have more positive
values and as we go to the left more
negative values hopefully you at this
point in your life while studying
chemistry you're familiar with our
number line anyway to the right here we
have more positive electron affinities
which means that more energy is required
right to add that electron this is less
favorable right and this would be a
lower electron affinity okay whereas to
the left
that's a release in energy a more
negative electron affinity that means
that there's more energy released right
this is more favorable so in this this
is in this situation adding an electron
it more readily occurs so the electron
has a higher the the atom has a higher
affinity for the electrons so we have a
higher electron affinity so the simplest
way to remember is simply that the more
negative the electron affinity the
higher it is right so values to this to
this side right whereas more positive
electron affinities are considered lower
electron affinities because that's
that's an indicator that the atom really
doesn't want to have that other that
electron added to it okay so let's
explain this trend if we go down a group
what happens to atomic size right as you
go down a group atomic size increases
right so the
Tron's are further away from the
positively charged nucleus right so if
they like well the electron that's
coming in is further away from the
positively charged nucleus so the
electron is not as attracted to the
nucleus as it could possibly be because
it's further away so that's a lower
electron affinity okay
across a period however the effective
nuclear charge increases and the
electron that's coming in is probably
again is gonna be more attracted to that
higher effective positive charge right
thus we will have an increase in
electron affinity right now again an
important thing to keep in mind
important reminder is that this is a
trend right this is a trend increasing
up into the right there are many
exceptions with electron affinity more
so than with atomic size and ionization
energy so just keep that in mind
so here's some examples of two
exceptions the first one I'm gonna cover
really really briefly and that's the one
with with neon so here we can see that
neon is a noble gas and so the value is
actually shown in parentheses here but
you'll see that it's a positive value
right more positive is a lower electron
affinity right we just said that
so neon has a a a lower electron
affinity because it's stable in a noble
gas configuration right it is a noble
gas and it does not want to gain another
electron so it would require energy to
add an electron so neon does not have a
high affinity for an electron okay so it
has a little electron affinity so but
let's look at the rest of this trend
here let's kind of cross off neon now
just so we got that out of the way
that's example one example of the
exception but that's something we
already mentioned noble gases don't have
a high electron affinity because they
don't want to grab another electron well
let's look at these other atoms on the
table carbon nitrogen oxygen fluorine we
can see here that the general trend is
becoming more negative values restarting
negative 122 here this is clearly an
exception right going to a more positive
value here so we're gonna have to
explain that but then we have negative
144 141 which is more negative negative
328 more negative so the general trend
is that it's increasing this way but
nitrogen yet again is an exception so
we've got to explain this why would
nitrogen have that that that lower
electron affinity well again we're gonna
look at the electron configuration and
the orbital diagram so nitrogen if as a
gas would could gain electron to become
an N minus ion okay the N just nitrogen
itself has an outer configuration of 2s2
2p3
right half filled which is stable okay
that is stable if it gains an electron
it's gonna become 2s2 2p4 when it
becomes that and minus ion so now we've
got repulsion here right we've got a
repulsion between these two electrons
this is not as not necessarily this as
stable right so we would say that this
is not as stable right so in this case
the electron affinity reaction results
in the nitrogen being less stable than
it originally was right so this nitrogen
really does not want to gain another
electron right this nitrogen pointed out
here this does not want this electron
right because it's not going to result
it's already stable and happy the way it
is okay so that's why the trend here is
broken okay
so hopefully you've noticed by now at
least from this video in the previous
video is that when coming across
potential exceptions or unusual
situations you should always look at the
electron configuration and more specific
we you should look at the electron
orbital diagram right because if you
look at the orbital diagram you think
about just dig down a diagram and you
can use that to help you figure out
what's going on in terms of you know
half filled orbitals fully filled
orbitals stable not stable all that sort
of stuff so uh I hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying